there's no sugar coating it energy bills
this winter are going to be very grim
indeed and what's been particularly
frightening this week is just how
quickly forecasts have changed this
shows the energy price cap going back
all the way to 2019. now look the light
blue bars over here is what the cap was
predicted to rise to last week pretty
big numbers but just look at how that
forecast was updated this week the
prediction for january alone that middle
bar jumped over 650 pounds now the big
jump here is partly explained by a
change to the off-gen methodology but
that won't make things any easier for
the customers
kirsty is facing a challenge similar to
almost everyone around the country she
just doesn't know how she'll pay her
bills this winter she's self-employed a
mum-of-one and her energy is set to soar
we were paying 90 pounds on our gas and
electricity at the beginning of the year
but they do a forecast for you to show
what the next 12 months could
potentially look like and when i've
looked at those figures today it's
petrifying there's one month in january
they're predicting up to 560 pounds a
month i cannot comprehend how anyone can
pay 560 pounds a month on their gas and
electricity and then our mortgage could
go up a couple of hundred pounds as well
on top
it's frightening because you you know
how can anyone just find that kind of
money it's it doesn't exist does it
so why are things so bad and what can be
done well this is the key cause
wholesale energy prices it's been
skyrocketing it peaked during the
invasion of ukraine but it's creeping
back up again now now many will say that
this is the reason the price cap needs
to go up but although this affects the
whole market not all customers in all
places are seeing the increases we are
have a look at this this shows how the
uk
has the biggest proportional gain in the
price of their energy bills across the
whole of the g7 look 57 our bills have
gone up now there are some localized
reasons for this but it also has a lot
to do with the degree to which
governments are willing to help so this
is the value of our government's most
recent most notable intervention on
energy 15 billion pounds it'll mean 400
pound per household some targeted
support for the most needy as well now
this doesn't cover everything but it is
worth having a look at what's going on
in other european nations look in
germany a package in excess of 60
billion euros italy nearly 50 billion
euros and i just want to draw your
attention to france because in france
the energy price cap has been frozen at
prices as what they were in october and
the government is picking up the
difference
now while these numbers are not directly
comparable to what's happening here they
give us a rough picture helping people
further will have to come in the form of
political intervention and pressure to
do that is mounting